advertising helps the organization know
their competitor's potential and plan
accordingly to either level up or
outperform the competition altogether
if any company wants to introduce or
launch a new product in the market
advertising will make a ground for the
product
not just competing against your rivals
but advertising can also increase
familiarity and trust between a company
and its customers
this critical requirement of advertising
is the reason why the top marketing
giants are searching for a performance
packed professional who could research
the market and bring a dominant market
presence to the company
major marketing giants like wells fargo
cognizant ebuy and many more are equally
looking out for certified professionals
and are also ready to compensate with
attractive salary packages ranging from
7 lakh 50 000 to 12 lakh rupees per
annum
this potential requirement opens up
lucrative career opportunities like
advertising sales public relations
creative director copywriter marketing
communications manager and many more if
you have the zeal to get yourself landed
on one of these carriers then scale-ups
complete google adwords professional
certification program is just what you
need
this course is curated in collaboration
with leading advertising giants and
real-time industry experts making sure
the program covers the critical skills
techniques and hands-on experience with
the powerful advertising tools to make
sure that the learners are industry
ready the best part is all this for free
of cost yes you heard me right and you
can start your advertising journey for
free of cost this course is 13 hours
long and all the modules are self-paced
video lessons with 90 days of access to
the entire course this allows you to
learn at your own pace anytime and
anywhere after completing this course
you will receive a course completion
certificate from skill up this
certificate can be shared within your
professional circle the course comprises
cutting-edge technicalities and around
google adwords which is the leading
advertising tool first we will learn a
brief overview of google adwords then we
will look into exploring keywords and
match types followed by that we will
deal with search ads and ad extensions
then we will learn about display
targeting later we will focus on one
campaign type and settings for the same
advancing we will deal with some
critical advertising metrics down the
line we will learn about bidding and vet
modifiers finally we will wind up the
certification program by understanding
the quality score by the end of this
course you will be an expert marketing
and advertising professional
so now you might be thinking who is
eligible to take up this course well
there are no prerequisites to enroll to
this course each of you who has a zeal
for learning market research and
advertising can take up this course
irrespective of your experience so what
are you waiting for head straight to our
scale up page and enrich your market
research and advertising skills with
google adwords by enrolling in our free
course today
get closer to your dreams and what can
get better than a free certificate to
strengthen your profile certifications
bring you one step closer to backing the
opportunity and becoming a google
adwords expert today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here